is there a place where ai can help
sorry to inject one of the things i'm
very
excited about i'm passionate about so uh
deep
google deep mind recently had a big
breakthrough with alpha fold
two but also alpha fold two years ago
with achieving
sort of state of the art performance on
the protein folding problem
single protein folding but it also
paints a hopeful picture of what's
possible to do in terms of simulating
the folding of proteins but also
simulating biological systems
through ai is there something to you
combined with this brilliant work on
the biology side that you're hopeful
about where ai can
be a tool to help where isn't that a
tool and if you're not using ai right
now in biology you're getting left
behind we use it all the time
we're using it to generate these
biological clocks
to be able to read those scratches we're
using it to
predict the folding of proteins so we
can target molecules and modulate their
activity
we're using it to assemble genomes of
different species
uh what else we use it to uh predict
the longevity of a mouse based on how it
reacts to certain things
hearing eyesight generally frailty so we
have
we just put out a paper last year on
that
the other thing we can use it for which
is a little off the track here but
we use it for predicting which
microorganisms are in your body
actually not predicting telling you so
our daughter um natalie was infected
with lyme disease a few years ago
almost went blind from it and the test
took four days and i thought
just give me the dna for my spinal fluid
i'll go tell you what's in it if it's
lyme disease or not
they refused and so at that point i said
this has to be done better
so i've started a company that now can
take a sample of any part of your body
it's typically done now with transplant
liver transplant patients
to detect viruses that come out of their
organs
but that's that's another area that ai
is extremely important for
um i i think if you're not in five years
if you're not using
you know deep learning you've got a
problem because the amount of data that
we generate now as biologists
is just terabytes can be terabytes per
week it'll eventually be terabytes per
day
and then we just go from there and i
actually have trouble recruiting enough
bioinformaticians a lot of our work is
now just number crunching
you